in two weeks and six days we'll see how
it plays out for this year's crop of
first rounders peter isn't it amazing to
think that we are right it just it
doesn't feel like we're as close to the
draft as we are because
this year
with no combine
with now we didn't have private workouts
last year and everything got turned
upside down with the pandemic but this
year feels like it's even more impacted
by the pandemic than last year was even
as that cloud seems to be dissipating as
it relates to how the pandemic is
affecting us on a day in and day out
basis
well mike you know i i keep saying to
people you're never gonna get
john schneider the seattle seahawks or
howie roseman
of the philadelphia eagles to admit
that
they are
one of the reasons that they were okay
with
either trading out or trading down
in this year's draft is because they
view this year's draft
as a
massive bit of uncertainty
okay because
no scouts at games last year
so many opt-outs of really good players
think about this
the two top tackles in this draft
consensus you know top tackles sewell
from oregon slater from
northwestern
they have not played a football game in
400 days
and you know
some there's gonna both those guys most
likely will be picked in the top 12 or
13 picks
so
and i'm not questioning their ability i
think they're both obviously really good
but
let's be honest about what is missing
this year the ability to look at players
the way you have traditionally many of
them didn't play in 2020
none of them were scouted the same in
2020 as in any year before there's no
scouting combine there's no individual
workouts at your facility nothing
so
there's a lot of dubious people
in the nfl right now and why do you
think that the philadelphia eagles for
instance have loaded up on the first
round in 2021 because even though maybe
right now the the experts say
the crop might not be as good well
you're going to know that crop a lot
better and be able to make your picks a
lot more confidently next year than you
are this year
yeah that crop is always a crapshoot
when it's time to draft and it's even
more of one this year just like last
year but even more this year because
last year there was limited information
in the run-up to the draft but full
information from the prior football
season this year
limited information from the prior
football season limited information in
the run-up to the draft no scouting
combine this year unlike last year it
really is even more of a shot in the
dark with some of these prospects and
you have to trust your scouting
department to find a way to give you
some basis to believe that a guy is
going to thrive at the next level
when we know that for every guy there's
a ceiling somewhere between whatever he
has done in college in the pro football
hall of fame and it's impossible to
figure out where that ceiling is that is
the biggest challenge in scouting and
that is the thing that makes all the
time and effort and money that's spent
it at times feel meaningless because you
just don't know peter how that guy is
going to respond the first time he faces
nfl caliber competition is he going to
win or is it going to beat him and is he
just going to be relegated at best to
career backup status and that's the one
thing that will constantly elude these
scouts and these folks who think that
there's some magical formula out there
there isn't because you don't know what
that guy's gonna do until he gets
for lack of a better phrase hit in the
face by a grown man
sometimes you rise up to that challenge
and sometimes you don't and you don't
know
what that guy is going to do until he's
in that situation
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports